the tour rolls on y'all Edmonton I'll be
there in a couple of weeks September
29th through October 1st Chicago I will
see you guys in November the 11th and
the 12th and Grand Rapids I'll see you
all December 9th and 10th get your
tickets to those shows and all shows on
my website at ryanstickler.com
the Honeydew with Brian sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media thank you again thank you
every damn week thank you this community
continues to grow
um you guys are the best if you are
watching on YouTube subscribe it is a
free way to help this show and uh it
really works and means a lot
um wherever you are listening subscribe
subscribe subscribe and if you gotta
have more then you gotta check out the
patreon it's called the Honeydew with
you all where I'm highlighting the low
lights with you all you guys have the
craziest stories I've ever heard in my
life and I've been we have an inbox of
hundreds more it's insane and it's not
going anywhere all right it's five bucks
a month if you sign up for a year you
get over a month free and you get the
Honeydew a day early ad free at no
additional cost all right if you or
someone you know has a story it's got to
be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com and hopefully
we'll get to do an episode together all
right the night pass Nation Tour rolls
on Edmonton I'll be there September 29th
through October 1st Chicago November
11th and 12th in Grand Rapids December
9th and 10th all right now that's all
the biz right there you guys know we do
over here we highlight the low lights I
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers and I am very excited
to have this guest on the Honeydew first
time here ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Chappelle Lacey welcome to
honeydew yes sir
I'm all clapped out
um thank you for being here it's a
pleasure to have you here yeah thank you
for having me man um will you please
before we get into your story plug and
promote everything and anything oh okay
yeah I got some tour dates uh I gotta
read it yeah that's fine yeah uh so
October 13th through the 15th I'll be in
Raleigh North Carolina at good nights
and then October 21st through the 22nd
I'll be at the Milwaukee improv and then
November 17th I'll be doing a
one-nighter at Irvine Improv all right
and what about your social media working
social media that's Chappelle Lacy
everywhere well actually I only do
Instagrams Instagram on yeah everything
else exhausted you have a website yes
Chappelle lacy.com there you go yeah
that's where you find out all my stuff
well I'm I'm really excited to sit down
because I follow you I'm a fan of yours
I've been following you on social media
and stuff and I see a lot of different
things I see cheerleading I see Punk
Rock singing uh yeah I know you were
adopted yeah but I don't know your story
so
um why don't we just go back to to day
one for you and let's talk about it it
was a cold morning January 23rd I'm just
kidding is it January 23rd birthday
isn't it I don't know if it was cold
because it was Arizona but yeah I grew
up in uh Arizona you know uh like I said
I was adopted in my teens but originally
you know with my biological mom and
stepfather and then four other uh
siblings and uh you know it was crazy
you know I mean we grew up in a poor
area in Mesa Arizona you know not not
many people know you know much of
Arizona other than Phoenix but shout out
to Jimmy Eat World because they're from
Mesa I always got to give that shout out
Hometown Heroes but then uh yeah I uh
you know I grew up in a crazy crazy
household my stepfather was very very
abusive and
um it was obviously tough for
you know one to navigate as a child
because you have so many questions
especially when you know this person
isn't your dad but you know let me ask
you this you're in a house with three
other siblings uh four others four so
it's five total five total kids and you
all share them you're the same mom so
yeah uh so my I only have one
full-blooded sibling but he passed away
we'll get there eventually uh but my
three other siblings they're my half so
they're from him from him yeah okay yep
so yeah that's uh that was pretty much
our household uh growing up and five
kids under the age of what uh man I was
so I'm the second I was the second I'm
the second oldest uh and my youngest the
youngest was born in 92.
and then the oldest was born in 85. so
we got a lot of young kids
and he was abusive huh to your mom as
well you know he never he never
physically you know
touched or anything but you know
verbally yell at her yeah and then you
know just the mental you know abuse
um you know he made it feel like she
needed him and she couldn't be anywhere
like on a very manipulative what did he
do for a living I said I don't know
bro he came in with different uniforms
all the time
I couldn't tell you what he did he did a
lot of difference that's my favorite
question if he was like what did he do
for a living I'm like what I don't know
he made up [ __ ] one day he was at Burger
King next you know he was a security
guard somewhere yeah it's all good right
I'm like it's for as hard as he works to
lie about where you working I mean you
could have just worked a job but uh no I
don't I don't know where he worked my
mom was you know that was the work ethic
of the house okay you know she was a CNA
I think that the nurses assistant yeah
she she worked at the the hospital where
pretty much all of us being all my
siblings were born at you know she was a
CNA there so she was you know at the
house or or the bread maker of the house
she was yeah and my stepdaughter
collected yeah now my stepfather he was
just chilling yeah
he wasn't good at chilling you know what
I mean now what can we go back to your
biological father you know I know I know
did you know
like do you always remember your
stepfather being the guy in your life at
that age yep you do I didn't uh I didn't
know I had a biological father until I
was
10. so you thought up until 10 that this
man was your biological father no I
didn't even I didn't know I knew it
wasn't my dad we looked too different
but no I didn't I didn't think of him
it's weird because I didn't even call
him dad I called him by his first name
you know so it wasn't like
I don't know like it was just weird I
didn't think of him as like a dad but
that was the
adult in the house you know of anything
was Dad but a parent was you know
different with you than his kids yes he
was yeah was he abusive to them as well
not not too crazy I mean you know he was
strong with the verbal abuse but I I
don't he never really like
you know
not not the way he treated me and my
brother who weren't his
you know we were you know me and my
brother we had the same dad but our dad
was locked up but they it's crazy
they all knew he existed but I was the
only one that didn't even your brother
knew at the time yeah my brother knew
yeah because my brother was two years
older than me okay and my brother before
my our dad got in prison he would see
him and like he had like a little bit of
a relationship with him what was he in
prison for uh uh attempted murder and uh
drug dealing [ __ ] like that all right
okay but yeah yeah no that's what he was
in there for all right so what happens
to a for you to be adopted in your teens
so it's it's wild you know I
it's so much that ties to it but
I was a competitive cheerleader right
and this was at 15 I started
cheerleading and why what got you into
that I had a crush on this girl let's
talk about it man that's what got you
into cheerleading that's what got me
what the [ __ ] yeah
get you every time
guess what guess what never happened
you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
so the the competitive cheerleading is
like like what you would consider like
club soccer it's not through the school
it's like uh outside of the thing and
you pay to do it uh but the owners of
the cheerleading gym that I cheered at
um those are the ones that took me in
okay yeah so like I was cheering there
and I think they knew there was
something wrong you know with me I was
very quiet very reserved and didn't talk
much and couldn't look people in the
eyes really uh and so I I you I mean and
they've been working with kids for years
you know my my adopted uh father he was
a teacher for a while so I mean he would
see all types of you know children come
in and out of his life and I it I think
he just knew immediately something was
up and you know he didn't never had
never asked detail you know but just
they would just like take care of me you
know they you know was this a legal
adoption
did they talk to your mom about this
before no no not at all because my
stepfather he had he kicked me out he
kicked you out yeah he kicked 15 you're
already out um he kicked me out like 17.
he did yeah but they started taking care
of me pretty much like and your mom just
what wasn't going against no you know
you know it's so weird my mom and I
recently talked about that because I
didn't I didn't know how she felt when
she saw me get kicked out because she
she my mom worked the overnight shift
at the hospital right and I remember
that morning very clearly uh
uh I I you know I woke up for school and
my stepfather he was always on some on
some [ __ ] and then he he used to do this
thing where he would tough guy bumped me
just because like he wanted to show
dominance right I was like [ __ ] I
scared you no I'm just kidding uh I was
uh but was he big uh big enough big
enough yeah for when I was from my
bigger bigger than me now hell no but uh
when I was younger obviously you know I
didn't grow yet you know wait till I
grow though
right
[Laughter]
no but uh he uh
he yeah so you're a tough guy about me
and then one day I was just like man
stop like just quit it like what like
you know I just you know said something
back you know I was just standing up
standing up for myself and then I
remember he didn't like if you talk back
to him it was like you know a major
thing like it was it was you know a big
No-No and I remember he just like shoved
me and just started you know shoved me
into my my closet and just started like
wailing on me and stuff yeah but I was
just like you know tucked or whatever
right and then
um
I get out of this I get out of it I run
across the street because his mom lives
across the street from us and so which I
consider her my grandma you know I I do
even to this day and because she was
like a lifesaver you know like whenever
I'd run to her house because he was
terrified of her no yeah he's terrified
yeah yeah so she would she would hide me
there we go I found that weak point I
was like it was a generation
I found that kryptonite
[Music]
oh big time you know because she knew
how much of a nut he was you know but I
think just I mean no one knew what to do
really like and I don't think I mean it
it's that type of experience and most
experiences in life I think is first try
for everybody so I don't know like you
know no one knows what to do but also
like it's like you know it's because
it's like family so it's weird like I
don't blame any anyone for
my childhood like I have no animosity
towards anybody but that's just it you
know it is what it was you know and I'm
here now but uh you know so yeah she she
was like and I think one one day she was
just sick of it and you know she tried
to tell him but he was still on his
tirade and I remember I walked back to
my house and my mom just got home from
from work and uh my stepfather had all
my all my stuff packed packed uh packed
up in trash bags and had it on the stair
on the little Little Steps right there
and then um told me to leave and I was
so happy you were happy huh oh my God
bruh best day of my life so you go to
their home not immediately I went and
lived with a friend
uh for like a hot second and then I just
told them I was like you know I was like
I don't have anywhere to go I was like I
like you know doing the cheerleading and
stuff like that but I was like I got to
figure out my life because I don't have
anywhere to go and then they just you
know brought me in so you got adopted by
a white family yeah shout out and what
was that what was the difference like
for you man because it you know they're
very like they're all about love they
were you know strong Christians you know
uh very into to to the faith uh can I
ask you one more question yeah yeah go
ahead during this is your are you still
having a relationship with your mom like
man that was a tough one because yeah
what's happening or
you know what um
I was so for years
I was so 50 50 with my mom I was like
man I I don't like this lady but I do
like this lady you would see her during
this time and not often no no and how
far away are you in like 20 minutes
ain't nobody all right
about an hour walk you know
[Music]
you know so yeah I was so 50 50 with her
because
you know like I was like yeah she you
know she's with this dude
but she's my mom was never mean to me my
mom was always very sweet and kind did
you feel like betrayed like how could
you pick this guy over over me or your
kids as you feel yeah I did feel that
you know
um one thousand percent you know what I
mean and are they still together no no
no not at all but they but they still
have to see each other because yeah I
have a brother and I have a brother with
special needs okay so uh whenever like
he has like doctor's appointments or
anything that you know so they that's
when they still have to see each other
and you know just to get them get them
stuff but
um other than that yeah like I was I was
pretty messed up about that and I I
wanted I wanted to love my mom but it
was very tough because
you know she was with that dude you know
and and she you know stuck with him for
so long you know even after I was a
after I was kicked out you know so I
mean yeah
but like I said with the recent
conversation I had with her I'd say
almost uh a year or so ago
I never knew how she felt when when she
saw her son get kicked out I didn't know
what
you know what went through her head I
didn't know I mean because my family
wasn't a family a family that would talk
things out we never said I love you in
our house like there was just like
pretty much like just
nothing nothing of that nature and uh
you know she had told me she was like
you know the day you know uh stepdad
kicked you out
that's when I was like she was like
plotting her way you know trying to
figure out how to how to get out of the
situation so that was the beginning she
was so yeah she was so mad and you know
she I know it's not like a major move
but she was like I made him sleep sleep
in the living room we never slept in the
same room we were totally like she was
checked out but she just didn't know how
to exit you know because I mean she'd
been in that situation for years you
know what I mean
so so I brought you off track let's go
back well go ahead you now move in with
this family what are the differences
like you said oh yeah so the difference
yeah very Christian very loving do they
have three three daughters three
daughters yeah they have three daughters
of their own and at the time the
youngest daughter when I moved in the
youngest daughter I think was two or
three uh
uh in the old African Africa all their
damn ages uh forgive me uh but but yeah
I moved in with them and
it was uh yeah it was it was a big
difference you know like I would see
them whenever the kids did something
wrong
I'd be like
you might get [ __ ] up
you gotta get your glasses
you getting it coming to you no and then
uh I would see them like talk to them so
I was like what like what is that you
know and and that's how they were with
me you know they never like raised their
voice never never saw any aggression
and that's all I knew so I was always on
edge
you know I was always I always had the
guard up you know just ready for
something to happen you know even even
with my even when my adopted father woke
me up one time because
so my stepdad whenever he would wake me
up
he would like shove me or like kick at
me or something right so I remember one
time my daughter father tried to wake me
up and I was like
trying to get you over a nice hot
breakfast
some [ __ ] you never had
yeah
he was just like I got oatmeal
downstairs
I just wanted to wake you up we got
orange juice
I'm sorry oh man yes I'm like you know I
was like what's up homie yeah it's funny
you gotta get unconditioned and then
learn and get used to yeah
that's literally what I was exactly I
was a rescue
did you have your own room had my own
room which I never had before because I
shared with all my brothers you know
which wasn't like that wasn't weird to
me either like I didn't think of us
being poor like a weird thing I was just
like yeah because because every I mean
even if kids at my school like I'm like
oh they got the same [ __ ] we got like
right I just didn't think of you know us
not having money as a bad thing you know
but yeah it was very different I had my
own room had a TV I was like damn bro a
bed you know like it was just like you
said like the most what I like the most
[Music]
um
damn that's a good question I've never
been asked that what did I like the most
I mean I don't want to give you answers
but you know
were you excited to be in a loving home
was there Freedom was the living room
the loving home I wasn't like used to
yet okay that that's still weird that's
still weird yeah yeah so that's that's
still a weird thing I think it was just
the fact that I had my own room and like
my own space you know like I just never
had that you know I think that was like
the cool
it was the first time I was able to like
really
sit with myself in a room that was mine
and decorated for me
you know so I was just like wow this is
this is trippy you know what I mean and
I was able to sit with my thoughts a lot
and you know I'm a thinker I think all
the time I just be sitting there
thinking and that's all I did on the
regular and then this family's paying
for yeah food food costs for whatever
these Athletics things are yeah they
made you their son yeah pretty pretty
much they did you know what I mean they
really did but it felt weird I'm not
gonna lie did you feel like I'm asking
you this not I want you to know that I I
so I'm only saying this to everybody
else like Jesus Christ shut up but my
father died when I was 16. yep and my
mom was already out of the family and I
remember when my dad died people went to
the store and they bought new
sweatshirts for us and new clothes and
when they brought it over they felt like
they were doing the kindest thing and I
felt like a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
charity case yes did you feel that way
yeah because I mean because you got to
think
my siblings are still in that situation
I felt so much guilt
and it's weird because I knew that
wasn't like it's almost like I wanted to
go back
because they were there right
because you know
like I I didn't like him at all like as
it wasn't it wasn't like oh maybe maybe
you know maybe it was my fault never
thought never thought that
I just thought I was like man my
siblings are still there and I felt so
bad and you know I'm I'm living this
life and you know they taught me how to
drive you know they gave me you know a
car to drive and what kind of car would
you drive it's a Hyundai Elantra shouts
out 99 baby yeah
um were you going to see your siblings
though you know the only one I saw uh on
the regular was my oldest brother okay
you know because he was a little bit
older and he in
he was old enough to like move out and
stuff and he had gotten his own place
but yeah he was the only one that I that
I would see out of them otherwise I
didn't really see
my siblings ever you know it was it was
tough it was I mean yeah you just feel
bad and then and then I
I was becoming like spoiled
you know because I mean these people saw
that I was in a screwed up situation
and these people are just being nice
I know they just want to be good to you
and be nice like you know all these nice
things I even I even ran away from my
job to folks uh one time like I I
remember did you begin to resent them
for all that
yeah
yeah because it didn't feel good you
know and I'm like why am I deserving
what authentic and it feel authentic you
know I was like this isn't this isn't my
family this isn't where I came from and
they're just trying to be nice you know
they I mean they were they were helping
out a kid and you know and I was I was a
wreck there was a lot of things that
messed me up that I
you know just never dealt with you know
or I mean it but it's tough but it's
like you know telling this kid in his
late teens or you know mid to late teens
like
how crazy his life is it's you know it's
a lot to process you know I didn't
really have any guidance until like
anger management you know anger
management is where I learned
a lot you know I think I was able to you
know accept a lot more
um because of that you know but yeah you
just feel this this weight on your
shoulders even though you're out of this
situation because that that that's that
situation I was in with my stepfather
was a lot of weight
but then you know I feel like there was
even more weight now that I'm not in
this situation and then look at the
situation I'm in right I'm looking at
this house that I'm living in
that has stairs
all right yeah come on man come on
yeah
I got stairs
you know but it's it's like even like
you know some people may think that's
funny but that's really what I thought I
was like man there's stairs in the house
I've only seen that on TV that's all
that's all I I've never seen it like
that you know so it's just
is well at least like living in it you
know I you know I knew people that had
stairs in the house but but living in it
I'm gonna stay here now but I'm in it
yeah that was like a weird thing to me
it's as simple as that is I was just
like I don't that's a perspective dude
yeah exactly you know so that it's these
little things that your stepfather ever
try to break down right
he was so glad too though yeah yeah all
right you know but also like I think it
was this thing where he thought I was
gonna come running back
how's it bro do you know where I live
you know the house I'm in right now no I
ain't coming back now yeah he he thought
like
yeah like if I you know yeah he gonna he
gonna need me that's what he thought I
gotcha you know we're making sure he you
knew that you didn't yeah I was like I
got you you know I used to tell my
mother all the time because she would be
like yeah I was like I don't need you
you know because This Woman's beating me
talking [ __ ] to me and I'm just yeah
I'll be fine I would love to go on my
own I'll be fine like she's like you
would never make it I was like [ __ ]
dude I've been on my own since I was 16.
so you know exactly where that's
beautiful because it's exactly that I
knew it yeah I knew if I had to I could
do it you know the the what's crazy
about you saying this the thing that set
my stepfather off what made him flip out
on me that that day that morning as I'm
getting ready for school was when he he
he goes move out get your [ __ ] and I
started packing started packing my stuff
and then he slapped my bag out of my
hand right and he was like you ain't
going nowhere with your simple ass right
he said that to me and I looked and I
was like
I got plenty of places to go
I'm all good and that's what
you know yeah that's what set it up he
didn't know where I had to go he didn't
know those people yeah he didn't know
that these people were taking care of me
he didn't know that he didn't know that
there was actually good people in my
life
he thought he was it he was like you
know I'm all you got you know and uh
it's it's so it's so crazy you share
that because it yeah I feel that 100 man
like the the visuals in my head of him
just saying you're never gonna be
nothing yeah you know you know you ain't
gonna be [ __ ] yeah you know and
meanwhile and I don't know if you felt
this too
when I when I when I thought about
myself on a regular I go am I I was like
I don't think I'm a bad kid no I don't
think I'm all the time like I was just
into skateboarding going to punk shows
and you know I wasn't selling drugs I
wasn't doing I've never been arrested
I've been cuffed I've been cuffed I
ain't never been arrested I've never
been arrested I never you know got in
trouble with the cops I gotta I I told
my mother that we reconnected after like
25 years okay hell yeah did you ever get
a call from the school
did you ever no that's right because we
were never absent enough yeah we never
[ __ ] off enough because we played
Sports and if you [ __ ] around you
couldn't place the whole thing was we're
getting good grades and we're gonna be
here every goddamn day that we can
because we don't want to [ __ ] up Sports
yes if I didn't play sports I probably
would have it would have [ __ ] ruined
my life bro because with no parents at
that age it would have ruined my life
that was all we had so it resonates hard
and what I I really think I looking back
on it I meant and I think you two like I
don't need you because what you're
bringing is nothing but a beaut I don't
need this yeah I don't need this I can
be I'll be fine without this like if you
were a good person great it'd be
different yeah but I don't need this yes
yeah so good for you yeah man I mean to
be able to to understand that because I
mean
you know that thank thank the Lord for
punk rock music oddly enough because
that was the thing that got me to stand
up for myself I would read these lyrics
of these dope punk songs and it was just
all about like standing up for yourself
and
and and believe in in what you know who
you are now Grant I was a little
aggressive you know to a lot of people I
was aggressive uh but and you know
that's where the anger management came
in you know took care of that but it did
you know it did get me to you know be
able to speak my mind and and say
something for myself all right I asked
you the thing you liked the most which
was your own room what did you actually
miss the most
from my being with my my original home
um man the thing I missed the most
my mom my mom would always at summertime
she'd always play these dope movies
from when she was younger and and we
would watch him all the time or even if
it wasn't movies from her era if it was
just like some movie she wanted us to
watch and it's just just specific movies
in my life that I think of when I when I
watched that movie I think about just
summertime and my mom you know being
home with us kids and us watching those
movies you know one of them is Trading
Places hell yeah
man that's so good I love that oh it
still holds up to this day and then the
way they give him the little love and
coming to America yes oh yeah oh [ __ ]
there's gonna be a new trade
yeah
you know so she she would show us a lot
of like and I I fell in love with Eddie
Murphy immediately
immediately I was like who's that guy
I was like that guy is the deal you know
I just loved all his characters and
stuff like that you know but but yeah
that's the one thing I miss is like me
and my siblings gathered around and
watching these movies you know because
that was if there's one thing I could
think of that was like probably the most
wholesome
part of my
time with them you know and even TV
shows my mom loved I Love Lucy she loves
I Love Lucy Mama's Family with Vicki
Lawrence like I and we would watch these
shows and and I'd just be dying laughing
because and I just connect with her so
much and you know that was one thing I
thought about when you know I moved in
with My adoptive folks I was just like
man and no one's ever asked me that
question either but that was the one
thing I missed it was like a bond with
my siblings and my mother and stuff yeah
my stepfather
you know he you know he I I don't
remember him I don't have memories of
him in that wholesome part yeah be
impressed you know what I mean so it was
just it was just such feel good
that was that was man that's that was
like the best
what um what were they watching it your
adoptive family yeah man I was like bro
yeah
turn this full house
can we please put Good Times off
can we where is JJ from Good tail I feel
like I know I said but the TV we grew up
on uh I'm older than you but man good
times The Jeffersons uh what's happening
yeah what's happening on the family all
the family cheers taxi like it was great
yeah comedy yeah great great comedy
[ __ ] comedy great comedy great comedy
um yeah I don't remember what that yeah
because I you know I I think I would
just go to my room oh my my adopted
father he loves uh
so now he loves the Hallmark Channel nah
yeah
yeah [ __ ] sisters and I like all my
Christmas shit's coming up y'all
need to calm down in there with a bad
boyfriend
I love these shoes but it's always like
it because he's always like there's
always a happy ending I'm like
so yeah there's that [ __ ] on other
networks yeah you know but but like and
it's so funny because my siblings now my
on my adopted side they're they're all
like not about it anymore you know they
used to be they used to sit there with
him and watch and I'm like man I I can't
our weeks are filled with deadlines
responsibilities and just stress in
general but it's football season and
when the weekend hits you've got to
protect your chill so this season make
time to chill out and catch the game at
your favorite bar and while you're at it
order an ice cold Coors Light the beer
that's made to chill Coors Light's the
perfect beer to sit around with your
friends crack them open talk a little
smack watch the games all right so
whether your team is a Powerhouse with
the record to keep or an underdog with a
point to prove one thing's for sure it's
gonna be a hell of a season stay
refreshed through all the action because
no matter how your team fares after the
clock runs out or Coors Light in your
hand means you're winning every time
protect your chill this season with
Coors Light get Coors Light delivered
straight to your door with drizzly or
instacart by going to coorslight.com
honeydew celebrate responsibly Coors
Brewing Company Golden Colorado I've got
Joe burrow throwing for more than 263
yards this week I think he's gonna have
another good game Lamar Jackson he's
going to be throwing for more than 220
this kid's probably going to be one of
the MVP Front Runners and Mark Andrews
that's just my guy he's going to catch
more in 65 yards this week those are my
picks prize picks format is simple and
easy to understand so even if you aren't
a sports fanatic you can play pick two
to five players and if they will score
more or less than their prize picks
projection you can win up to 10 times
your money on any entry no competing
against other people it's just you
versus the projections available and
there are projections for any sports you
watch NFL NBA MLB NHL PGA college
football college basketball ball soccer
WNBA Esports NASCAR tennis MMA boxing
disc golf y'all Euro basketball cricket
and more entries can be made in 60
seconds or less they're safe and fast
withdrawal and it's currently
operational on over 30 States and Canada
download the prize picks app or go to
prize picks.com to sign up and play
daily fantasy sports first time users
can receive a 100 instant deposit match
up to 100 bucks with promo code honeydew
if you deposit a hundred dollars prize
picks gonna give you a hundred dollars
if you deposit 50 prize picks gonna give
you 50. don't forget to enter promo code
honeydew it sign up for an instant
deposit match up to one hundred dollars
do you ever feel overwhelmed by the
number of plastic bottles and containers
you throw away ever thought about
purchasing more eco-friendly products
but didn't know where to start well if
you answered yes to either of these
questions meet blue land blue land is on
a mission to eliminate single-use
Plastics by Reinventing Home Essentials
that are good for you and the planet
blue land's Innovative tablet refill
solution takes up 10 times less space
than a traditional bottle and their
powerful formulas Keep Your Home clean
and smelling great the idea is simple
you grab one of the forever bottles you
fill it with warm water you drop in the
tablet and you get cleaning refills
start at two dollars and you don't have
to buy a new plastic bottle every time
you run out you could even set up a
subscription so you never run out of the
products you use the most from cleaning
sprays to hand soap to toilet cleaner
and laundry tablets all blue land
products are made with ingredients you
can feel good about try their clean
Essentials kit which is everything you
need to get started products come in
refreshing signature scents like Iris
Agave fresh lemon and Eucalyptus mint
and for a limited time their hand soap
is getting a summer upgrade with three
refreshing new scents strawberry rhubarb
Citrus Patchouli and coconut an up Palm
right now you can get 15 off your first
order when you go to blueland.com
honeydew that's fifteen percent off your
first order of any blue land products at
blueland.com Honeydew blueland.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
now do your siblings and your adoptive
siblings if you have you all mixed
families if you crossed to hung out no
no no never never so you were what 17
you said roughly when you finally you
finally moved in with them and how long
are you with them
uh I moved I pretty much moved because I
well I went away to college to go cheer
in Texas where uh Trinity Valley it's
the this
um you know that docu series cheer yeah
I mean I know of it yeah oh okay well
the school that that's that's one of the
schools that they're talking about is
with the school out here so that's a big
deal yeah you're cheering okay so and
um then I went on to University of
Louisville but I didn't even finish
there because that's where I started
stand up but I pretty much moved out
fully moved out when I was 25. okay yeah
that's when I moved out from so you're
there seven eight years with them and
the whole time is a good experience yeah
great experience a lot of learning uh
you know it did take me a while to get
used to the the loving uh that's that
took a little bit
um and I think were they Huggy were they
a Huggy family yeah and they would
praise and I'm like quit doing that you
know like whenever something whenever I
did something good it's just the way he
did it and I was like hey stop that why
you say it like that you know like it
and but that's just how they show
affection and love and that's fair you
know but I just wasn't
I wasn't about it like I remember
I don't know I did something right I
don't know if I got like a good grade on
something and it was like oh my God
that's amazing look at you and I'm like
hey yeah that doesn't feel right
you know I was like you know it really
felt like those TV shows that they were
watching right yeah but uh now I mean
now it's you know I get it and stuff and
I'm used to it now but it that all that
that took him that took a while to get
used to that and
you know
the youngest the youngest uh daughter
their youngest daughter her and I
connected a lot because you know I would
get home from school early and she would
you know she was a little baby I call
her baby and uh so her and I would just
be at the house all the time you know
because I'd be home early from school
and I would just play with her and never
really
did that before either you know and she
considers me like yeah I mean not even
considers yeah I'm her brother she tells
everyone all of her friends about me you
know she she's 19 now I think yeah
something like that but yeah she tells
all her friends about me she she I'm
like her you know her Rock which is
pretty which is pretty cool and I
remember
um
because my voice is loud and I didn't
know you know and I would talk
aggressive and I remember one time just
this little situation
where I was going out to clean the
backyard you know and I I just just used
to clean it like that was a pretty you
know thing that was the thing that we
did in our household you know with my
biological and stepfather like we we
just understood like cleaning was a
thing and I remember I was going to
clean the backyard and she wanted to
chill out hang outside while while I
would clean the backyard and I was like
no you ain't going outside with me and
she started crying I was like wait wait
[Laughter]
yeah and and I didn't know what to do
and I was like oh man she's crying I was
like I didn't even make this little baby
cry and then I remember I just uh I
picked her up and I was like okay it's
okay you know and I remember uh I was
like you know what you can come outside
with me and then she she kissed me on
the cheek and I was like
what and it was it was it was such a
moment to where
I've never ever in my life
felt that it was like this
it was it was love yeah it was pure love
that was pure love and I and I didn't
know
how to react I was just like oh yeah
yeah we'll go outside you know and and
to this you know to this day it's one of
those emotional things for me because
yeah coming where I come from that was
never a thing I'm telling you we didn't
say I love you we didn't we didn't have
a job good job yeah none of that was
ever negative oh negative time all the
time so
you know to feel that that was that was
the that was the first moment I ever
felt something like that
um you mentioned anger management yeah
um talk to me about how it helped you
and what what did you learn from it I'm
curious you know I learned a lot of
great things in Anger Management and I
would say the overall take so I I've had
three different anger management
teachers shout out uh I had one my first
one was in high school
uh the second one and the other two were
in
College yeah when I was like in my 20s
and no I didn't you know Say Hey I want
to go to anger management they put me in
sure yeah because everyone asked that
they're like oh you put yourself out
there put myself in there
but
the um the beautiful thing about anger
management is it taught me
and and there's still things that I
because I haven't gone since my 20s but
there's still things to this day that I
take with me and the overall take is
put it all on you
put it put it put it all on you don't
make it about anyone else you know it
and and I and I say that in a sense like
when I think about my situation with my
stepfather
how about I do right how about I don't
fall in those footsteps and follow that
cycle how about how about I just why
don't I just be a good person don't make
it about being angry at him don't make
it about that at all how about I just do
that and when I was able to figure that
out
I grew this empathy for my stepfather
and I started to learn and ask questions
about where he came from because I never
knew asking him these questions no I
would ask my mom okay my mom knew uh
knows pretty much I mean they were
together for years but once I had
learned about him
I was just like oh damn
I was like well this guy I think he I
think he and I'm not trying to make an
excuse
or you know justify what he did because
what he did wasn't good
but he went through some [ __ ] and he
thought he was doing right you know what
I mean and he would say these things all
the time to my mom like
he'd be like why does he think I was a
good dad you know like I was I was a
good dad and I used to I used to get so
mad at that question I was like how
Delirious is he and then I thought about
it
his dad wasn't around
his dad didn't even
come near him right so so the fact that
he was there he felt like he was doing
right it's going from zero to one like
well I'm doing good yeah he thought he
was doing good all right bro you sucked
do you know what channel right here you
even know what channel number it is no
but you know it and it made me feel this
way about him that I don't think I've
ever felt because I I felt so much hate
towards him and I and I wanted to go
after this man I wanted to attack this
man I wanted I wanted him to just not
exist
I wanted all that but then I thought
about it
and
you know because I started honestly
through comedy in a weird way I started
doing these jokes about my abusive
childhood
and then I noticed when I was on stage
you know as you're working jokes you
know you you [ __ ] just bombs and it was
bombing I was like I hate the fact that
it bombs and then I was like well why
does it why do people not connect with
it and I was and then I would listen
back to some of the [ __ ] and I'd think
about it I go oh I sound angry I sound I
sound like I'm still hurt
I sound like I'm upset I go what if I
wasn't
and so then it made me just dig and dig
and dig and understand more and more and
more about him and then even you know to
this day and like even current current
date he and I are cool you are yeah what
was the first time you had a good
conversation I don't know if it was a
good conversation as much as it was just
like
I accepted the fact that
I I looked at everything I had right in
front of me right I looked at everything
in my life and I go
I'm fine
I'm fine
and when I was able to do that I was
able I think it wasn't even anything as
much as I shook his hand when I saw him
and I that caught him off guard did it
yes
you know the fact that I shook his hand
and I was just saying hey how you doing
and and and obviously through with that
tone and that energy
you know because I obviously he feels
something you know
uh some sort of Guild but there's he
didn't get what I he didn't get what I
got he didn't get an anger management
teacher right he didn't get these things
and probably didn't even exist that [ __ ]
he didn't get back then yeah yeah what
the [ __ ] are you talking
right yeah
yeah right yeah
[Laughter]
and I found the beauty in just going you
know what I'm fine I'm okay and I know
you've been through some [ __ ] and I
understand that and I don't even take
anything
that happened in the past personal
and that's taking a lot of work dude
that wasn't that wasn't that wasn't
overnight
it's like a lot of work he takes it
oh I mean he's still like you know at
times he he does get he's a little quiet
around me you know because that he
doesn't know what to say but you can be
but I know he's in room yeah it could be
in the same race together yeah I can
yeah I could say anything good yeah why
not I got his number yeah yeah I'll text
you what's up does he ever hit you up
about your like man you [ __ ]
brother's [ __ ] up or nobody was ever
ask you to talk to them or anything no
not nothing like that I mean my brother
they reach out to me in general they've
kind of just looked at me as like the
you know respectfully with no arrogance
as like a as a North star you know they
kind of look up to me and because you
know it was our oldest brother that we
all kind of in a sense looked up to
because you mean he's the oldest and you
know he's he was moving in ways you know
that that just like you look at it over
older sibling and you know and uh so I
think when he had passed you know tell
me about that so you know my personal
biological you said biological brother
you know my only full-blooded sibling
and you know that was uh that was a
tough one you know because when I think
about my brother and I he and I went
through some [ __ ] together you know
especially in the home you know with
with my with our staff other
and going through that thing together
and then losing him
man really that was that was a tough one
I felt like I lost my soul
um he was the only full-blooded sibling
I had he was like my protector you know
like I mean there's times I'd be you
know getting in a fight right and he
would roll up and I'm getting me and
this dude are squaring up and he would
always swing on this dude before I could
and I'm like you know it's it's my fight
you know hey you know I could throw a
hand the two you know but he was just
like that he was just he didn't like
seeing and I think that's just because
of what we
you know what we were going through
because he couldn't do anything to our
stepfather because he was bigger than us
so like when he sees someone you know
just squaring up with his little brother
in a way to where it's like and he would
just he would just snap you know and
unfortunately you know he he had got
into pills
um right so which is
an easy thing to get into especially
where we grew up you know poor area
you know it's just that's just what it
was you know it I mean from from my
earliest memories I think everybody was
just kind of on some [ __ ] and you know
my brother had some demons you know but
he was a great [ __ ] guy
and he he didn't get what I got either
you know he didn't get the the anger
management or someone to
necessarily talk to you know I would try
to share things to him whenever you know
uh whatever I learned through the anger
management and stuff how was he when he
passed he was 28 28. he was 28. remember
how yeah I remember exactly where I was
I was going I was flying to Florida to
go compete at a cheer comp uh for a
world title for a world title yeah yeah
and then when I got off my flight and I
was in baggage claim I had a message on
my phone and it was from a police
officer and I guess they found my
brother
um he OD'd in his apartment man I'm
sorry so so what happened was
he my brother had had a struggle with
pills for
for quite some time he was like on and
off right and then he had got a really
good job working for Budweiser in the in
the factory like you know he was on one
of them what do you call them damn
things he was driving around the factory
Cliffs yeah he was on one of them
I was like damn bro what's that thing
called he did [ __ ] let me call him up
let's get it no so he was uh
you know he worked a really good job he
was so excited for this job because he
he fought hard to get this job and it
was a hard one to get you know it was an
easy one to get and when he finally got
it he was he was going straight you know
he was he was he was doing all you know
all the all the correct things and I
think
you know based off what they expressed
to me he just had a night and he took a
dose that he would normally take
but he had been off it for a while
so so
yes so it was toxic yeah so like there
wasn't any struggle as much as it just
it just stopped his heart so
so when he um so yeah I got I got that
call I called and you know I already got
the message on my phone they were like
hey can you give us a call when you get
when you get a chance I call and no one
knew yet and meanwhile like I was flying
from you know the west coast to Florida
so that's a six hour flight right so no
one knew no one had any information
because the cops called you they called
me because I was like the guy you know
next of Ken yes and so
um emergency contact yeah yeah emergency
yeah and so
um well yeah when I got that call and
they they told me what happened
and obviously I went I was in I was in
baggage claiming I was in shock and I'm
like man I'm like what the hell like I
was like are you sure it's him you know
and that's like the first question
anyone with that sure you know naturally
it's like what you sure you know but
they were more than sure obviously and
uh I remember
I was like man I got two decisions you
know I'm going to compete for this world
title for cheerleading something I've
been doing I've been doing for years and
you know still didn't have Marissa so uh
kept going
really long yeah she's long gone I'm
still going yeah I'm still trying eh you
know maybe a world title be like oh damn
maybe maybe that impress her what about
this uh
and I and I decided to do the
competition you did yes and only for one
reason
my brother was the only person in my
family that ever seen me compete
he was only only one of my family that
came to my competitions so I was just
like okay
I'll do this hell yeah yeah
and uh that was that was not easy you
know and I was very quiet
no one knew you didn't tell anyone uh
just my team knew you know but people
would see me around and you know they
just noticed I was very different very
quiet
um but yeah it was
you know that was that was a tough one
that was the and to be able to hold
hold myself together you know through
that Grant it was Cheerleading uh but
still you know and we we won the world
title you did yeah we won yeah yeah yes
congrats yeah yeah so your world title
you're a world uh Championship
cheerleader yeah is that how is am I
saying it right yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah you
could say that
I got Rings yeah I got Rings though
wow what did the Marissa ever come back
with cheerleading three years ago yeah
right yeah exactly
done family married kids she was like
will you still do that oh that's crazy
good for you you made the right decision
yeah you know and it felt good and so
after that that was when
that's when it all hit me
it all hit me uh it hit me pretty hard
you know because I got a huge check for
his uh for his death because he made me
the beneficiary on his uh life insurance
and I got a huge check and I
I [ __ ] hated having that money
I hated it yeah it was at that it was
and so
I was down I was down man I was my soul
was just ripped apart because like I
said my brother was you know like my
protector
you know what I mean and
um you just don't think that's gonna
happen to someone and then I I was like
who I don't have anyone
for protection you know I was like I
don't have that protector anymore you
know and and when you lose that it's
like
I don't know man I I I I didn't want to
kill myself I didn't want to do
self-harm but I just didn't want to
exist I didn't want to be around I
didn't want to I like I had planned on
moving to a
some random town somewhere and just
live in a normal regular
life paycheck to paycheck
and
and just that that's what I wanted to do
you know and
oddly enough through that money I had I
just started helping people I just
started giving people money not just
like hey you know but like if I just
noticed someone in need
I just be like here you go
you know hey let me get that for you let
me let me let me catch that I just did
that and then
that started making me feel better
I just I just started organically it
wasn't like oh I just did something for
somebody no it was just
you know the fact that I could do
something for someone else
made me feel better and it and it takes
you out of this
um
it takes you out of these like these
individual thoughts that you're having
that are just about you
and you you you you no you have to take
care of you but also I think
when
if you have the strength and ability to
do so
and to help someone out even if you
don't have the money that I had
I mean even someone that's just you see
do you see some people outside moving a
couch and they're struggling with it and
you go over and help them and it's just
something and you're not wanting any
reward from it you're not wanting any I
don't like that's that was my thing I
was like I don't want anything for it I
just hate looking at this bank account I
hate I hate opening up my bank or
looking at my bank account just seeing
all this money it's interesting you say
that because I I totally again you
resonate with me because here you are
living for a while with a family in a
home that makes you feel uncomfortable
yeah now you got money that makes you
feel uncomfortable yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] it's interesting yeah cause well
you know this is how I thought of it I
was like you know what I could get it
was 75 grand and I was like I didn't
want to ask oh no you I don't know
everybody's like an ass
I'll say it I don't care uh I was like
you know I was like
I was like I could get 75 grand again
but I can't get my brother back that's
it I'd rather have my brothers I'd
rather have my brother than 75 grand I
think anybody well most you know yeah
yeah
some people got some weird siblings no I
just I just I'd rather
that and there's just this spirit in me
that
all of a sudden I was
in a sense a little bit
able to feel what it was like to to
protect somebody for a moment of time
even even though it wasn't as much as my
brother protected me and I was able to
feel that you know just by helping a
person out that was struggling with a
bill or something and you know needed
anything and I just like
there you know just just take that you
know I don't need anything I don't want
anything you have to tell anybody I gave
you that but just just take that and
some people didn't think I was crazy you
know what I mean but I'm like if you
were in that situation
you you and you felt the way you felt
about this yeah you feel the way I feel
about this then you probably wouldn't
say that well also I mean
when I say it means more to them than it
does to you it really does you know what
I mean like those people need that money
yeah and you're like [ __ ] this money
yeah it means more to them
so if you have a bunch of money and
you're not getting any joy out of having
a bunch of money and then giving some to
people that make that helps them gives
you Joy then there's a purpose for this
money now yeah well could you make you
feel good about having this exactly I
got my soul back right I got I was able
to rebuild my soul
you know in a dope way to where I felt
good about myself you know I was
in
it like I said I didn't want anything
from it but someone just reaching out
and saying hey that really did a lot for
me when you when you did that
I appreciate that it meant that meant a
lot like you didn't have to do that you
know and and just hearing that from
someone
like almost just makes you
just grow into a selfless person
you know and try to help people as best
as you can yeah and
anyone that like I I don't I don't know
you know everyone's different
but I know when I was depressed
there was something about helping others
that just
help myself
in the weirdest way I don't know how to
explain it I haven't gotten that far yet
but when I do figure it out and able to
break it down in a well that's
intellectual empathy that you've
developed because if you didn't you
would be like [ __ ] these people this is
I'm not helping anybody yeah yeah it's
it's freeing yeah it's um
I don't know I like to do it as much as
I can anytime I can I was in Cleveland
um
we bought tickets to the [ __ ]
I always want to say Toy Story Christmas
Story house and then I'm standing
outside and Evan and I are out there and
I'm smoking a joint and I'm like I don't
want to go in and tour that house like
it's a movie set it's not a real house
it's a movie set inside I didn't know
that either so people are like yeah it's
kind of not I was like oh I don't I
thought this was an authentic home we
were going to walk through I'd be I was
like I'm smoking a joint in front of the
Christmas Story house this is all I
wanted to do so I see this family with
kids and it's expensive so I go and the
kids get in free so I went over and I
was like because their kids were like
can we go and they're like yeah and I
was like here here take my tickets oh
wow take your [ __ ] kids in there yeah
yeah I just want to smoke weed out and
that's all you want to do yeah
I mean that meant more to me and and
they're gonna remember that yeah you
know there's something about that
feeling yeah and I can't I can't yeah
fully explain it to people like the
exact feeling of what it is but it just
it's the it's a feel-good feeling it it
does something to the to the soul
in a way that
you know it will come back to you I mean
I don't know how you know I don't want
anything you know but I just I just
wanted to put that energy out there we
have family members that stole I can't
tell you how many thousands of dollars
from us when people died and
over the years that eventually it came
back you know what I mean in a different
way but it came back it wasn't like I'm
without that money for the rest of my
life yeah yeah and then I was like yeah
[ __ ] you
you know what because you spent it all
let me ask you this how are you and your
mom today how's your relationship man
our relationship is beautiful good it is
it is one of the coolest relationships I
think I have today uh because
man we
like I think there was just so much
that wasn't talked about and
my brother my brother due to my
brother's passing that's when her and I
reconnected because I saw something in
her that I've never seen before
I I think I always saw a sadness in my
in my mom and when I think about it now
uh with being being in that house
um but
I saw something that was she lost her
first born yeah
a child that you know she created and
she did the best that she could
to take care of you know what I mean and
watching that look on her face
I was just like damn
and then I was like and then it made me
think about everything that she went
through
and all of a sudden I saw it I was just
like oh wow
she was going through it too
she was going through with you know with
my stepfather but just not in the way
that I was
you know what I mean and then just
because she you know we weren't going
through it the same way doesn't mean
nothing was
like her doesn't mean her world was
positive and so to see and understand
that I was just like damn
so I would just call her every day you
know and and
before whenever I would try to call her
because like I said I used to be 50 50
with her and I was like I'll call her
let me call my mom I was like I'm all
the way out in this
State you know
this random State she don't know where
I'm at I was like let me call her
and it was tough to have conversations
yeah it'd be like three minutes
and I said like I'm done with this you
know but now we we I call her you know
twice a week you know she only lived
five hours away in Arizona but we talked
for a long time we talked for a good
while
you know and and I love it you know I
mean it's it's really cool and even with
my my biological father reconnecting
with him I want to ask you about that
yeah when did that happen
so that was shortly after my brother's
death as well
um that was I think I was 20 I was 29
was was your dad out at that point yeah
he was out he was out uh I think he had
been out for 10 years okay after
or yeah he had he already when my
brother died he already had been out for
like 10 years
so I didn't know anything about him I
knew he existed
I had seen him a couple times you know
and knew about him on Facebook but I
never I was always quiet around him I
didn't say much
never had really much anything to say I
kind of just was like
yeah I was like I don't know what
because I was like I didn't know about
the guy you know so it's like weird it's
like I I know he's my dad I know that
but I don't know
that I was like I just don't know
anything about him and
um
I don't know what it was it was he
because we were I was friends with him
on Facebook and he would post these like
pictures from when he was younger like
pictures of like from when he was locked
up or when he was you know
you know doing the [ __ ] that he was
doing
and finally I was just like
let me I was like let me just I just
reached out to him I said can I
interview you
and he was like
I would love that wow really yeah
and then I remember driving to his house
because he had lived like an hour and a
half away from me I was just like okay
if it goes bad
then you could say you tried
that's so that's that that's it it goes
bad you can say you tried because you
think about that you think like I don't
know how it's going to go but if you but
when I thought about I was like you know
if it goes bad you can say you tried
it's not like he was in your life
already so it's just like all right
whatever and so
go over there and I just asked him
anything and everything
and he answered it he answered
everything what sticks out do you really
remember the most
um
man
probably that shootout he had with that
some Colombian drug lord
yeah yeah he had some crazy shootout it
was so Colombian drug lord yeah
something something wild I don't use
Columbia Cuban I don't know he has some
shootout
and then he said they came and shot up
his house after whatever he never saw
the dude again but it was a guy that he
had worked for worked under
you know and then that was that was one
that I was like oh damn okay you real
deal so where is he now he's in Arizona
and do you still talk to him yeah okay
good yeah talk to him all the time she
have a good relationship with your
biological father we talk all the time
you're on Solid ground with stepdad yeah
and you're in a great place with Mom yep
in my adopted folks and how old are you
I'm 35. good for you dude yeah and
you're adoptive folks yeah yeah my
doctor folks too weak I mean he tied
them all together yeah like every you
know
yeah it is weird because like I do feel
equally about all of them in a way to
where I'm like yeah that's my it's my
family and my mom doesn't get weird
about my adopted folks my mom don't get
where that you know my stepdad or
stepdad or biological father like no one
gets weird
about those situations you know because
it's because they all love me right they
and they all know that
you know the the kid that they all
have a part of their life is trying his
best you know did your mom and dad
connect a little bit over your brother's
passing a little bit
at least a little bit Yeah because I
mean yeah that's their child their
firstborn yeah you know what I mean and
yeah and to see in to see you know my
biological father deal with that too
because he
you know and he had said something
he told me when he was in prison he goes
man like he goes all I thought about
it's like I have kids
you know it got to a point
because he was in survival mode you know
he he was locked up in a very tough
prison in Arizona and he was he was just
constant in survival mode he was just
like man I got I got kids
and I want to be in their lives
but he just he's just like but I'm here
you know eventually he studied law
because he was supposed to he's supposed
to be serving a life sentence so he
studied law
and found out the system had messed up
in some way
uh something with signing people off
when they like I don't know I don't know
the details but like you can Google it
and uh but he studied law and basically
got himself out no way yeah really damn
yeah that's impressive he went back in
see what I didn't tell you that part he
went back in he went he went back in he
went back here
yeah yeah I'm like bro you study to get
yourself and you went back and do all
that work to go right back I know man I
was like you want your ass off we had 20
books that's too good dude thank you for
coming on yeah yeah of course great man
no this is great man um all right uh I
mentioned at the beginning before we
started recording after everything we've
talked about here now what advice would
you give to your 16 year old self
um
what advice would I would give to a 16
year old self
take more deep breaths
I say that because
I do that now
if I feel like I see a situation that's
in front of me that's you know
to where I'm like
it's like you know tense I just go
I just keep doing that and I think I
wish that was something I knew as a kid
because that tension was so heavy yeah
all the time you know
I just wish I didn't have my guard up
so strongly and aggressive because I
there were so many great people
that I think I missed out on
um growing up growing up that we're
trying to
you know also show love and help and I
think
I would you know yeah love to tell that
kid take a deep breath and see those
people over there
they're good people they're good people
too you know and I think I've you know
due to my aggression and just being a
rescue
I was just aggressive all the time and
there's some good people I think I
missed out on that's great advice yeah
um again thank you please uh plug
everything you want yeah uh at Chappelle
Lacy uh on Instagram Chappelle lacy.com
for my uh website tour dates all that
stuff uh I think October 13th through
the 15th I'll be in Raleigh North
Carolina at uh good nights and then
October 21st and 22nd uh Milwaukee
improv and then November 17th a
one-nighter at Irvine Improv very nice
yeah come here and talk some [ __ ] yeah
go see him uh and as always Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all social
media we'll talk to you all next week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]